[Music]
my elbows drop in one
you'll feel
[Music]
don't feel your hand drop your elbows
you see our doing that not here at the
shoulder the store then drop your elbows
underneath it
[Music]
disliking coca-cola lastly he has to be
he has to be following that way you get
him so if my if if he's not falling
until I entered that's the class yeah so
he's going to come in
I'm going to lift him right he's falling
and just like pokeball I set a geometry
up where he cannot stand you get I'm not
throwing him down so this is the yield
with the connection you'll feel you'll
feel you'll feel him and I'm now gonna
go around that their keys problem it's
not me going like this do you see you
get that hook and then I'm not doing
[Music]
you don't have to try to get them you
just push it you're surprised how far
you come we try to get from
you
[Music]
you know picturing that he's gonna fall
backwards if he does that so that's your
solution your mathematical solution and
so what happens is that you solve for it
in obvious ways I'm going to accelerate
in backwards there's many variations of
this one right you come here see that
handwriting there's some of the ones
we're seeing on the back here but those
are all clashes and energy against
energy no matter we showed it to you are
you going that way and I've made your
hand go to officer hood okay so we kind
of know what we want the solution we
have to solve for a different way just
like what people okay so what I need to
have this this yielding I need to have
that blending I need to have that
connection you understand it's just a
fraction of a second if I do if I don't
have that because I'm going like that
then I'm trying to solve it the other
way I have mass and I'm accelerating
your mass in the officers dress yeah so
I gotta have a yielding
and a connection that allows for the
initial unification got it and then what
I have to do is Aikido everything that's
pushing on me I am going around in I'm
not going to push that body okay so I
don't it changes every single rep except
for this this part tends to be the same
or at least feels the same but after
that what you're feeling is just like in
your net wasa don't push on that go
against that that thing's pushing on you
you get it try to keep your stance free
because if I'm pushing on that you would
feel it in your sails because your
stance is not mobile whether you adopt a
bracing angle right it's probably the
top of you you're going to get pinned so
I'm trying to solve for nothing
everything everything that's pushing so
it's more like he just hits book nothing
every time all around
[Music]
but you are so Allah not yielding enough
you
[Music]
I'm just standing and I changed the
geometry of the encounter hood I don't
throw him I just changed the rule okay
so I'm not flipping him like a tizzy a
fine I'm saving him at the end okay
[Music]
okay
you